tonight on Kitchen
Nightmares Gordon goes to New Jersey and
somehow ends up in the tropics but this
is no Paradise this park jungle par
restaurant is in deep financial trouble
and what makes matters worse it is run
by a category 5 storm girls shut your
mouth already named Adele who is not
fond of her staff Isabelle you don't
know when to shut up who was
disappointed by her Chef you just
started I don't even know how you
but the person who drives her nuts how
can you be positive about something you
hate is Chef Ramsey stop [__] me I
hate him hate hate
hate tonight Gordon Ramsey does his best
to turn around this New Jersey eer he
challenges Adele why have you asked me
to come here he confronts an
uncooperative daughter you cannot sing a
problem no but it all might be for
nothing no oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God because this Tropical
restaurant might just be impossible to
save oh my God sometimes it's hard to
say goodbye to the past I am devastated
right
now
White House Station New Jersey a quaint
Village surrounded by Rich Farmland it's
a popular place for New York commuters
to
live Bill and Adele ran successful
diners here for decades we made with the
previous businesses approximately a
million dollar I said that's it I'm
retired I'm done I'm finished hey
Charlie it was
nice when we retired by the third day I
was bored but in 2006 they came out of
retirement to open their first fine
dining restaurant with their daughter
Cheryl Chop Chop we love Florida we love
the tropical atmosphere so I thought
Florida hyphen mangoes
flamingos they wanted to be kind of a um
high class
restaurant and it's hideous hideous
beyond
belief this restaurant is very poorly
run we know we have big problems here
Adele doesn't respect us girls we know
Adele tells him to shut up and she's
actually cursed shut your mouth already
[__] Adele is crazy go all right here
I go I do the state I do the raw one
I do all the maintenance it's really
hard I get really upset when I see Bill
having to overwork like that this man
should be retired I think they said
medium medium rare medium
rare the food here is
fabulous you're not going to serve that
to him are you yep I've been a chef of
flamingos for about 4 weeks the food
right now it's less than
mediocre
I definitely wish I could redesign the
menu but they don't want me to change
anything what do you want me to do
flamingos is doing lousy and we don't
know
why I can't sleep at night because I
think of all the money we spent that
would have been our retirement money
taxes are coming
up I see us out in the street almost if
this goes belly up I could lose
everything how I and a start
over I can't think of anyone else that
could help us but Gordon Ramsey I mean
he cuts right through the [__] and we
are in deep
[Music]
[__] White House Station New Jersey not
exactly the New Jersey I know look at
this
place I'm here to visit a restaurant
called flamingos there's a long time
before lunch so I'm going to visit the
family at home rather than go straight
to the
restaurant y the smell of
manure it's
strong
yooo
wow that was a road and a half good
morning good morning Chef Ramsey Gordon
please good to see you Bill yes Bill yes
good to meet you sir how how old are you
I am 70 you look great for 70 you know
that thank you and you're setting this
up for a few years time for retirement
or what well I'm supposed to be retire
now but I bought a restaurant instead
and now I'm
broke you honestly came out I came out
of retirement to open a restaurant to
open a restaurant oh I had restaurants
before I had about four of them before
and I made a lot of money with him but
this one is I don't know what's my with
it I need chef ramy's help to try to
make this a successful restaurant for
Cheryl and Adele and likeing me Chef
Ramsey how are you oh nice to seeing the
big question for me is you had a
restaurant yes yeah we started diners so
then you sell them you go into
retirement right why would you come out
of retirement to buy another restaurant
she wanted to do this as a family my
daughter Cheryl and myself would you
like to meet Cheryl please
Cheryl hello good to meet you good
likewise now do you just pop over for a
slice of cake no I live here you live
here
yes how old are you I'm 42 years
old same age as me I left Mom 24 years
ago yeah what are you still doing
here I haven't had a paycheck in 2
years I have to live home my daughter
Cheryl she's still living with with us
but she doesn't bring anyone home no
guys forget that okay should we get to
the restant sure let me drive you there
let's go on a little Scenic rad yeah
yeah let's go princess
[Music]
okay so tell me who came up with the
word flamingos no it's flamingos
flamingos flamingos flamingos flamingos
flamingos it's flamingos not flamingos
flamingos he F f/ mangoes not flamingos
not flamingos flamingos yeah Flamingos
restaurant in New Jersey yeah why not
are you [__]
crazy there you are thank you so much
for the
LI wow Florida
Mango
Jesus wow wow wow wow wow wow wow oh my
God it's like a zoo in here yeah well it
is tropical who designed it my daughter
decorated it amazing how drunk was she
when she put the final sketches together
we do like the tropics I don't see
anything wrong in bringing tropical to
White House station this is jod she's
going to take care of you okay brilliant
thank you D well do you start this one
is endless okay um let's start off with
I Tuna on the Flaming Tiki platter Tiki
and then on I'll end up with that
tsunami on Philly M okay thank
you okay this is for Chef Ramsey all
right I think Chef Ramsey's mouth's
going to drop to the Flor when he sees a
few of the things on the menu AR tuna
appetizer thank you
[Music]
enjoy is that always that hot in terms
of spicing they have a tendency to spice
things up a bit it's an embarrassment to
tuna yes I'll sh to taste that other
little end there I will thank you my Dar
Brian Cheryl Chef Ramsey would like you
guys to taste the tuna it is really
spicy I've been saying it since I got
here I never had a problem doesn't
matter if you love it or not everybody
else four times I've got complaints
about being spicy so he's he's done with
it ribs are destroyed Sunday we made
those it's a week four days whatever
send it just send it out send it
out
wow I see PL like that I hear Hawai
music oh my God so we use that and start
grilling away or it it's for looks thank
[Music]
you what the
[__] stuck are you trying to get the
smoke detectors to come no I'm trying to
get the thing off the
[Music]
top excuse me having a world-known chef
spit out my food is not good Ticky
platter shitty platter we need Bill
ready to car a play tell my father to
put his his black Chef coat
on Cheryl want you to put your black
Chef coat on next phly Min so I'm sort
of looking forward to a really nice
classic piece of meat they show you
where it is strip down baby I'm not
looking get
excited we have a flaming flaming young
that I serve of table size people just
love the chef's dream
fion something simple something
classic and something that's not
normally served on a
[Music]
trolley what the
[__] what is that thing these are roof
tile reading it from the tile yeah I'm
going to finish it it's still cooking
you'll love this yeah I love
this what's that in there this is butter
and garlic oh garlic butter mhm they go
around
top and so the tsunami is the garlic
butter running down the drain pipe right
watch out all the stuff ding at the
end wow you enjoy that thank you very
much quite
welcome
wow
[Music]
me that's the toughest the most
cheeriest filin I've ever tasted in my
entire life being so
chewy have meat so tough you want me to
yeah no I I finished take this out your
way than
you Chef Ramsey hated the food he hated
the decor and I can't understand
why less than impressed with lunch good
to meet you Chef Ramsey is anxious to
discuss flamango eclectic Cuisine with
the head chef and how long you been here
um about a month what's it like cooking
that food does it blow you away are you
excited no it doesn't blow me away I
think it's all over the place straight
up would you eat it no no but you happy
to serve it to me
when a new Chef starts in a restaurant
he wants to put his imprint on the menu
right but they don't want change right
now who doesn't want change honest right
who writes the menus we do why wouldn't
you listen to your
Chef I don't know it's frustrating for
me too because like I said I've made the
suggestions I've said we need you sent
it to me you sent every [__] dish to
me and it was embarrassing that's not
cooking that's dog [__]
we take pride in what we serve and he
just ripped it apart it's
awful coming up you can make this work
if you believe in it it's a test of
Wills how can you be positive about
something you hate I need to know that
you're committed okay so stop [__] me
it's the battle of the owner you don't
freaking listen and the world class Chef
if you're not going to embrace change
shut the shot who will stay how stupid
can you be an absolute nightmare a real
nightmare and who will go I need to get
out of here I would rather close the
doors and later a shocking event that
will bring Gordon and Adele together
sometimes it's hard to say goodbye to
the past but it might be the end of
flamangos oh my
God Chef Ramsay is already aware that
the food is horrible and the chef is
really an unhappy cook but before Gordon
can even contemplate making changes he
needs to get the complete story by
observing a dinner service what name all
right you can follow me when the dinner
start coming in just start throwing some
asparagus on put it on the side the
menu's large the menu is a little all
over the joint it is you know really big
I don't have time to Red this it's got a
lot of things on it tonight's dinner
service is busier than usual because
Chef Ramsey is in town you ready to
order and as customers order from this
massive menu I'll have the crispy
rainforest CIA okay tickets are flying
into the kitchen here we go calam M but
the challenge to perfect such a huge
variety of dishes is overwhelming for
Chef Bryan I don't even know what to do
absolute crazy you know that huh yeah
got way too many tickets up here you
can't have 400 things on your menu you
just can't do it I don't care who you
are doesn't
matter we're absolutely buried over here
buried we don't even have these set up
yet
unbelievable although Chef Ryan is
slammed in the kitchen it's like it's
like a circus over here the customers
are not exactly sympathetic what going
we've been here
since
wayo now I don't know if you want to go
over to 20 CU they're ready for first
well I can't do it they're all waiting
the am say something you like we know
shut your mouth
already absolute crazy Adele's attitude
is completely toxic and it trickles down
from us to the patrons it's 45 minutes
into dinner service and Brian has
finally completed the first orders I
need his food out of the window right
now however just as fast as dishes are
rushed to the dining room are really
small and the Roto very they are quickly
returned to the kitchen hey guys the
shrimps are just way too small and she
said the red rice the risoto was just
bullsh oh my god I've had it today
already I've had it why am I here that's
it I'm taking a break [__] this right 2
seconds bottom line I mean it was just
about overwhelming disaster disaster
major the menu I was thrown into and
it's a disastrous menu how can you get
passionate about cooking something you
hate it's all over the place it's uncook
right I need to know that you're
committed committed to change cuz they
have no clue this restaurant turnaround
cannot depend on them it depends on you
sticking with me is that clear
absolutely okay thank you now that Chef
Ramsey understands Brian's issues they
head back to the kitchen here I go
meanwhile bill is ready to serve the
tableside tsunami I get tired real quick
but to help the business I'll do
whatever I have to do is that well done
no it's me rare if you just cut that a
little bit you'll see it's medium rare
all you have to do is cut
itut no but I mean cut it this way cuz
it was sitting on it hot tile it's not
medium rare okay I'm sorry oh
they got a 7-year-old man going around
and around the dying he shouldn't be
doing this at this pace I know well
they're too cuz they're too cheap to
hire anybody else what they trying to do
put the father in the grave I mean he's
got one foot in there already he didn't
even want to do this he didn't want he
wanted to that's what hurts bill is
overworked and it's not
fair after a night where he witnessed a
dejected Chef unhappy patrons and an
overworked older owner Gordon knows he
has to have a serious talk with the
tough mother daughter team of Adele and
Cheryl I wanted to talk to you both
personally and express my concerns about
Bill I'm seriously worried about him in
a big way running around at the age of
70 pushing the cart why are you guys
letting him do this he really doesn't
work that
much you know what it's always poor
Bill that's Bill's nickname poor Bill
why have you asked me to come here cuz I
feel like I'm wasting my time because we
don't know what the problem is the
service downstairs tonight how was that
the kitchen was a disaster so you've
employed the chef yeah mhm and he hasn't
been given chance to cook he's cooking
your menu right well I we never changed
the menu since we open we never gets a
chance to show you what he can cook
because we felt that our food was very
good Christ are you
[Music]
stupid I guess I
am you're accepting that it's perfect
I'm trying to tell you bluntly that it's
not yet you never seem to accept your
own mistakes it's never you're doing we
thought our food was good but now you
just you know said it's horrible you
cannot see a problem in your own
establishment
no I'm being honest what I would like to
see it's just a little bit more
Integrity with owning up to the
responsibility to why this place is not
working there's no acceptance on your
own
mistakes good
[Music]
night Chef Ramsey realizes that the only
way to begin to fix some of these
problems is to do something these owners
have never done have a staff meeting
it's so important to clear the air if
any want anything to say please talk
about
it I'll listen to anything doesn't mean
I'm going to agree to it the menu needs
to be simplified are you kidding cut it
way back people want to come in here and
cut off shorts and have a beer and a
burger yeah but you just started I don't
even know how you
cook thoroughly
yet you've got to have the confidence
and allow this man to step up to the
mark you need to be a little bit more
entrusting on that and less nervous
about letting go I can't do my job if
they don't let me do my job okay next
question I can't understand why the F
you don't like me well Isabelle you're
an excellent server but you don't
freaking live L but I know what I'm
doing I don't need to be constantly told
the same thing over and over again is
please be quiet why would you think you
have to tell me when I've been here for
2 years I know what the f I'm doing
Isabelle you don't know when to shut
up they don't want to hear opinions
we're still going to get treated like
garbage I don't think they're going to
[Music]
change coming
up a firestorm no one saw coming
oh my
God will it destroy flamangos and tear
this family apart horri that's coming up
on Kitchen Nightmares
no centrally located next to the train
station flamangos has managed to push
away its local customers today Chef
Ramsey begins his plan to bring them
back we're going to start making some
changes yeah I am afraid to make the
change change number one let this man
cook something that he wants to put on
as a special tonight without any
interruptions from you
two second change Bill what is your
favorite dish to cook my meat love what
was last time you cooked it 8 years ago
tonight you're going to cook that as
well really yes I don't want you around
there pushing the trolley out running
around like a blue
IDE both items will go on tonight as
specials my meatloaf that I've been
making for years that I haven't made a
long time it's going to be great to have
it on the menu
tonight your meatloaf what you seasoning
with fresh parsley and a little salt and
pepper I enjoy cooking a lot better than
pushing the trolley around what are you
doing chicken and shrimp Jubilee
Rosemary Gorgon Sol brown sauce Chef
Ramsey definitely let me have free rain
on creating my own special and I wanted
to prove it to the bill and Adele that I
can do it I can handle the job right
very nice take
again that is so good thumbs
up good everybody
happy I liked it but I would never order
meatloaf out never I can't believe that
Chef ramps he wants meatloaf tonight we
can't have a disaster so let's get set
up let's get prepped we're opening up
let's go guys
[Music]
yes as Chef Bryan and his team prepare
special for tonight's dinner service no
detail goes unnoticed by Chef Ramsey out
in the dining room what those Nails
what's going on there where happen are
they pretty pretty they're [__]
disgusting Chef Ramsey asked her about
her damn Nails Cheryl is
the80s are you high maintenance of what
huh seriously but I work hard yeah
unfortunately the wrong
places h no follow me all of our
specials tonight are excellent I'll have
a chicken i' like the meatloaf please
excellent
choice I think there's hope adding the
specials but will people like it I don't
really
know Brian I want to see you step up to
the MK tonight okay so get on top of it
from the out yes sir ordering three
Jubilee needo Chicken special come on
really big night tonight more
importantly these specials have to work
but Brian has to command the kitchen and
run it like a head chef because
unfortunately owners employed him as a
line cook tonight has to be his night
three jubilees picking up one meatloaf
many of the diners have ordered the
specials Chicken special and that has
had a positive impact on the kitchen
you're doing okay you're doing beautiful
Brian is not spread too thin and is able
to push out the food much more
efficiently than last night go with this
please please and in the dining room how
is everything bad meat Loof and chicken
Jubilee specials are creating a buzz
the out of this world while the original
menu is creating a slightly different
kind of
buzz it's over I'll bring the owner over
okay to talk to
you Adell yeah table 31 the m is
overdone they want to speak with you I'm
a little busy okay I know you're busy
I'm letting you know that they're
waiting tell them I will be out as in I
did that's what I did okay so stop
[__]
me I'm pretty fed up I'm treated like
almost stupid Adele can be downright
nasty and
insulting okay complaints what are they
okay Mahi it's dry dry so you don't
want
bastard I know when the customers come
in you have to to be positive but
they're
Liars go help us I bet you've see more
[__] in here than a mut spreader has in
New Jersey for the last 100 years see
you later my
friend M's killing me right here I'm
dying with the [__] sake lot of special
B the enging which helped a lot but I
was still discouraged with the old menu
it just got a little backed up oh we
missed the chicken penet get that going
on the flay the chicken breast working
on the
grill biggest panic in that kitchen
there is trying to get your head around
doing this menu there's so many
components in that menu that you're
reaching for this or reaching for that
that everything's just so sporadic
nothing streamlined and that's why it's
an Absol nightmare I mean a real
nightmare bye thank
you here's the good news Chicken special
meatloaf with f
hit now the changes may have been subtle
but it wasn't
enough nowhere near enough in order for
this to work whether Adele or Cheryl
likes it this place needs to take a
dramatic
turn in fact the biggest turn has ever
had since this place has opened it's
time to say goodbye to the tropics in
the center of New
Jersey everybody stand up grab a chair
for the dining room and follow me let's
go I was just wondering what's going on
grab a chair take two let's go oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God what's
going to happen oh hold on no what do
you mean no that's willly my alligator
trust me need him in the
truck I can't believe Chef Ramsey
grabbed my alligator and just threw it
in the
truck just threw it in there hey a with
my chair need the
[Music]
menus I don't think it's funny watch if
you want to keep your job right I want
that alligator they are not getting that
Cheryl and Adele are in complete denial
about this place nobody wants this tacky
tropical Decor they better not throw
that stuff out there's going to be a
[Music]
problem oh my God what is going on I
want my alligator come
over I had a very good feeling that this
is the beginning of the end of flamingos
Adele the only way I know where I leave
White House station that the tropics
aren't going to creep back in is to burn
them G to the menus G to the bamboo G to
the crocodile gr to the pineapples the
tropics are going my greatest fear is to
lose everything we worked for 3 2
[Music]
1 the only way I know when I leave White
House St that the tropics AR going to
creep back in is to burn
them the tropics are going 3 2 1 hold on
wait sorry I forgot the most important
thing the
sign say goodbye to flamangos I just
can't tell you how happy I am to see
that flamango sign gone ready I'm going
to leave you to the expert thank you so
much please do it quickly before they
change their mind
[Music]
anyone for cooked alligator that was a
good
one it feels great to watch flamingos go
up and fire Adele may be upset that
she's losing the Tropic but it wasn't
working this hot as Florida
here that is
amazing
wow that
right I don't want you to be upset
please she is you're going to make me
[Music]
cry I am devastated right
now A change is difficult it is and
sometimes it's hard to say goodbye to
the Past know
that it'll be all right on it will be
fine it's just the tropics the four
walls are fine we have faith in you the
past is gone it will be for the better
but Adell needs to come
around now I have regrets I don't know
what's to come so we'll see it's all
right
[Music]
baby
after getting rid of the tropics Gordon
now moves ahead with his plan to
transform flamangos good morning morning
morning how are we okay nervous I told
you the change would not be subtle and
it's important you Embrace change that's
not easy but it's for the best ready
ready goodbye Florida no more mangoes
welcome to the
junction how appropriate is that yes R
tracks junction means trains but
Junction also means coming together
which is what this community is going to
do on a daily basis they are going to
come together at the junction oh I Love
It Adele how does it sound interesting
interesting takes me a while takes you a
while yes I'm not happy about the name
come in welcome to the
junction oh wow oh my come my God look
at the size of this place to open up
this room was absolutely
crucial it looks twice the size oh my
God the wow factor was everything I
can't believe the wall is
gone the tropics have gone this
restaurant was claustrophobic it's much
more opened sand it down and distress
the tables to match the chairs the
pineapples have gone and and more
importantly it's just lightened the
whole place up look at the Raw Bar there
is no longer a raw bar this is milkshake
Heaven it's perfect it's a lot more
casual now I'm very excited about the
junction I what do you think I don't
like it you don't like it I hate blue
unbelievable I'm dumbfounded I don't
think I have ever heard anyone say they
hate the color blue I hate it
something I hate it how can you be
positive about something you
hate
ugly don't want to throw up I hate it
hate hate
hate oh my
[Music]
God the changes to what was once called
flamangos has been dramatic it's
terrible and Adele is finding it hard to
accept any of them
I love what we had that's all and uh
this is a very drastic change
and I really don't
like think about your customers because
this is not for you to sit and enjoy
this is for you to run as a business I
regret it right now but I want to see
the menu you know and see how it's all
going to come together Adele thank you
now this is trying to keep it in keeping
with what's happening in the community
it's diverse it's sophisticated and more
important it's modern how does that
reach for you I mean it's simple there's
a little bit of everything for everyone
yeah Burgers meatloaf we do a chicken
it's comfort food but it's fancy comfort
food there's no other place around here
like this what do you think of the menu
I mean this is very
limited very limited menu this menu is
so limited it's not going to be
successful people are not going to come
in with that small small menu I'm trying
so hard to help here yeah there's one
thing I need to say to you is you cannot
be personal about Nostalgia that hasn't
worked and you have to embrace change
because if you're not going to embrace
change do yourself a favor shut the shop
and
retire she has to get used to it because
this is what's going to bring people
into this restaurant and Dell sitting
looking like she wants to throw herself
in front of a
train
[Music]
after Chef Ryan spent the day learning
The Junction's concise menu that looks
marvelous Chef Ramsey introduces the
staff to the new dishes if you just have
a look at the portion size it's in
keeping with the plate this is a
Hallmark not just a burger three
different mini Buffalo meatloaf and a
turkey burger the bigger portions glazed
salmon a simple delicious roast chicken
who'd like a taste dig in dig in dig in
dig
[Music]
in be somewhat moist
that's different that's good these
Salmons are so juicy I
salmon I
love tast like a fish Adele how's the
salmon Dy
oh the new menu is exactly what we
needed it's nice and simple but Adele
has a very hard time accepting change
this was their last chance to pull this
place out Just Go With
[Music]
It
it's 30 minutes before the doors open to
this new restaurant you got your salad
bowls yeah I'm ready beautiful and
everyone is excited about the menu and
Decor everyone except Adele who has
hidden herself in the kitchen on the
dessert station what are you looking for
apple crumb it's out Joe can you do
desserts yes sir here give me I'll take
that he's fine he can do a dessert all
right I need your smile
I'll be right
out I'm very nervous it shouldn't be to
my liking is to what the customers will
want I don't know if they're going to
like
this good first custom there I really
want to go home did you just say you
want to go home yes I
did right now I don't feel my mother
feels she has hope the register has to
start ringing for her to feel more
confident cuz I know know she's
mortified as the restaurant starts to
fill up with customers Chef Ramsey
inspires the kitchen staff for the big
night right Bri you ready yes sir when I
get an owner like that out there that
tells me she wants to go home tonight I
need you get even more in control to
make this [__] thing work yeah let do
it yeah feel great about the new menu
this is a new beginning let's take it
from there dis guu the limit all right
let's do this this looks like a place to
be fun to come to every day really thank
you it's open it's um inviting right you
should hear what those people I know
they love it they love it and then it's
this is more inviting to go to than it
was before well screw down want screw
down they L the
money I'm going to have the chicken
Jubilee I'm going to have the glazed
Salon ribs okay chicken jubily lemon
chicken with the first orders in the
pressure shifts to Chef Bryan who must
execute the Junction's new menu we're
going to do a salmon and a jubilee next
so let's finish those put the whole pan
in the oven don't need a Sizzler plate
beautiful 20's in the window Che thanks
to Chef Ramsay's more focused menu Brian
is able to get orders out in a timely
manner table 30 in the window and more
importantly this is money the customers
are loving the food it's really good who
have thought you can fry a dill pickle L
of flavor it's very moist nice very
tasty I like this and it's it's some
bright it's too bright I don't like
it now where's the old where's mom what
I just don't have the patience anymore
for anything nice to see where is madam
grumpy where is she oh are he says it's
going to work how stupid can you
be can a quick word with you two seconds
wait what's the matter I'm very upset I
don't like this setup the dec work you
can make this work only if you believe
in it already you don't believe in it
the negativity is going to rub off on
your staff it's going to rub off on your
daughter and the Customs will we feeding
you I don't know we'll see I need to get
out of
here I have to be proud of what I'm
doing I am not proud of
this I would never run a restaurant like
this I want to go
home I would rather close the
doors
it's opening night at The Junction and
even though the customers are happy very
well SE Adele is miserable and ready to
leave I want to go home Chef Ramsey is
frustrated and he knows the only way to
get through to Adele is through her
husband Bill why is a down so against it
help me please she's that way but she's
our first point of contact if you could
do me a favor and just ask her to put a
smile on that face face okay yeah I will
do that Adele can't hide her emotions if
she's mad you're going to tell and it's
a struggle to get her to go in your
direction but I'm going to give it what
I got how you doing okay I'm scared I'm
so nervous don't be scared just keep
smiling
Smile
Smile here you go my mother is a hard
shell to crack my father is great he's
talking to her trying to make her feel
better
wonderful job it's delicious good you
enjoyed
it you like bills meatloaf yeah good I
wanted to tell you how beautiful the
chairs and stuff you like it I do she is
liing up is she liing up yes I don't
think I've got that long it's got to
happen before I'm 17 I told you she's a
p years yeah but you didn't tell me on
what scale of pain in the ass she is
she's 11 11 excellent
this is great oh good wonderful thank
you it was a success people love the
food and I feel that there's hope
everybody's happy very good good I'm
glad to enjoy in spite of the dramatic
changes the staff Rose to the occasion
done done and customers left happy and
now even Adele appears to be coming
around first of all I want to thank
everybody for all their hard work yeah
and a big thank you to the queen
[Music]
I'm
serious why there were a lot of changes
yes it was scary but you pulled it
off it's very hard to put the P behind
me I think the restaurant could be
successful but I don't know only time
will tell when I first arrived you'd
lost touch with your customers in the
community tonight you reconnected in a
big way tonight the junction even though
the history is very short it's only 3
hours old is a
success but it's only the foundation
okay you need to build on it together
Chef Ramsey definitely is giving us a
second chance and I'm just very anxious
to be successful and I see the light at
the end of the tunnel I will be back and
I'll take great pleasure in witnessing
the success and by the time I get back
Madam I want you moved out of that house
yes promise me I promise okay good well
done seriously well done yes what I've
learned from Chef Ramsey is change is
good and I'm up for it take can't wa to
see you and maybe I'll get some of the
money back that I put into this place
then I could
retire right good night good night good
night big kiss God it's so nice to see
you smiling like that you know that well
I'm glad you enjoyed New Jersey at least
this part of it I'm thinking of moving
here oh oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
God what a week we made some dramatic
changes here we changed the menu we
changed the decco we even changed the
name that honestly was the easy part the
hardest part was changing Adele she has
to look forward otherwise the history of
the junction will be a short
one God I'm a long way from home where
is my
train come
[Music]
in the days that followed Adele slipped
back to her old stubborn self and
started to redecorate The Junction the
new concise menu however remains in
place and is a hit in White House
station we're doing meat I like
that that's
good